final boss of Chess is usually pretty
tough Ali Raza faruja was eager to take
another swing at the King after two
draws at a trade of wins it was
Armageddon after the bids Magnus had
eight minutes and 55 seconds to take on
alireza with the black pieces alireza
had a full 15 minutes with the white
pieces surprisingly alireza opened the
Armageddon with the same opening as the
last game the game he won the evaluation
was constantly bouncing between equal
and in favor of Madness later in the
game the time Advantage actually
switched to Magnus and in this position
Ali Reza made the final Mistake by
playing Pawn to G5 this allowed Magnus
to promote and gain a significant
Advantage a few moves later it was all
over and that's why